reminder to email your to the point uh
queries to Roundtable reason.com this
one comes from Chris giri who writes I'd
like your thoughts on the idea that to
improve our Collective sensemaking it
should become a norm for at least all
non opinion news outlets to require
their journalists to disclose their
voting records reason does did he says
something similar yes uh and I think uh
this would be immensely helpful in at
least four ways one it provides the
reader with information that's important
context to the story the postmodern
consideration two it establishes a
baseline of trust between journalist and
recipient I'm putting my cards on the
table three it would encourage the
journalist to try to be more balanced in
reporting because Jero knows what bias
reader will be looking for so Journal
will want to proactively counter it and
for it would hopefully shame the
publisher into seeking out and hiring
journalists with different outlooks
which Jonathan Rouch tells us is
necessary for the constit tion of
knowledge to actually work I'm sure
there would be downsides to but thoughts
I have many of thoughts we'll get to
them but C do you want to lead off yes
so uh your the letter writer is correct
reason does do this has been doing this
for a long time and uh especially points
one and two are mostly the reasons we do
it um I am deeply skeptical that point
four has very much power uh because the
other publication that has done this uh
in the past
with some consistency although I don't
think they do it anymore is slate um
where they're like um they make Academia
look ideologically
diverse it's it's really something um
and people don't have any Shame about it
I mean this is we have these findings
over and over and over in all of our
Elite institutions that they are
overwhelmingly not just kind of um
philosophically liberal indisposition
but democratically partisan uh at at a
over 90% level you know everywhere
absolutely everywhere and uh no one no
one seems to be embarrassed no one is
ashamed um you know reason does it um we
will probably do it again and uh when we
do it a bunch of people are going to get
their panties in a bunch about it um
because someone on our everybody had
reason votes for Norman Thomas right
social stff is going to vote a way that
they don't like and
uh even if in their text of their
explanation they say this is the most
grudging possible vote this is being
dragged from me by Wild Horses only due
to a a tiny uh reason why this person is
marginally less bad than the other
person or whatever um the you know brain
poisoning of partisanship is so bad that
people will say look I added up all the
votes and you know there was one Biden
voter and two Trump voters and everyone
else basically just just screamed ah
into their answer but um you know that
means that reason endorsed Donald Trump
right and that's that's I wish that
people wouldn't do that because I don't
think that's the point of the exercise
but um what I think is the point doesn't
matter the whole idea of it is you put
it out there and people do with this
information what they will so if I may
uh Matt I want to thank you for
introducing that awful feature to reason
uh that came in when you uh darkened our
door and uh pushed uh me as editor of
the print magazine at the time to do it
what I found most interesting about the
um about the the way we do it at reason
was that you know people also talked
about previous votes uh and then uh some
other question and that we bring in
people in our universe that you wouldn't
necessarily hear about so it could be
pendulette or our you know cartoonist
Peter bag or or thinkers like Stuart
brand people who are adjacent to us and
that it just becomes an interesting
discussion of what's going on during a
presidential election year but also what
is a wide range of people you know who
are they voting for and why that can be
kind of interesting I think what the uh
letter writer is getting at and this is
a very different question at the New
York Times or you know the Wall Street
Journal or the Washington Post or you
know media that pretends to be
objective um that would be genuinely
fascinating even if they just tabulated
uh without giving the names they can
anonymize the data and just say you know
what like we pulled X number of staffers
who write on a daily basis and this
these this is the breakdown of who's
voting for whom or who's not voting I've
met uh and I'm struggling to remember
any of their names but that's because
I'm struggling to remember all names at
this point in my life but I've met a
bunch of like you know
high-profile Legacy Media journalists
who say I don't vote um because I would
be compromised somehow I think that's
stupid but I kind of respect that but I
I would love to see this I don't I don't
think it it it can be interesting as a
feature in Publications like slate if
they were ever interesting and it can be
interesting it is interesting in reason
style Publications but the most
interesting thing would be in these
other objective groups and I would like
to see that become a norm I do love the
weird reversal of cause and effect that
comes in U that comes in that line that
you just mentioned Nick like I don't
hear it as much anymore uh and I guess I
never thought I would miss it but now I
do but it it was a very very common
thing for a journalist to say I don't
vote
because that would bias me um which is
both like what no like the bias would
certainly pre-exist the vote if you were
biased but also is true like it also is
true that like if you commit to
something then you then you are more
likely to seek out its positive
attributes and downplay its negative
attributes like it's like a weirdly deep
psychological insight that I think
people are just saying in a stupid way
um so but I I now am retroactively
nostalgic for the days when at least
some journalists said that because now
uh almost every journalist at a
publication that would describe itself
as objective is in fact going to vote
for Joe Biden and many of them will
believe that not doing so represents an
existential threat um to the country and
to their own profession the other
variation on this which is good for a
laugh um is when uh the nation used to
do this all the time where they would in
every election there would be a
socialist a green party somebody who
embodied everything they stood for often
named Ralph nater and they would always
say Ralph we agree with you
10,000% but this election is too
important to vote for the person who
perfectly encapsulates what we believe
so would you please drop out so we can
vote for a candidate that we loath
ideologically but obviously support with
every fiber of our being and they just
do that on an almost regular basis which
is kind of funny The Intercept published
that exact piece about seven or eight
days ago without necessarily lionizing
you know Cornell West and and Jill Stein
but um saying you know oh what a
team two uh two could they be
co-presidents you know that would just
that's so perfect uh but uh was going to
say Catherine that I am my lifelong not
belonging to a political party is
totally out of that same impulse like I
don't want to join anything cuz I write
about this stuff um and also because I'm
not the Joiner of things at all uh Peter
because you're a moral coward Matt that
was a clip from the reason Roundtable
podcast to watch more Clips go here to
watch the whole show go here and
subscribe to the reason Round Table
wherever you get your
podcasts